it's time for our scene and unseen look
at the state of the union for that we
turn to fox news contributor raymond
arroyo
raymond we're going to get to that
little medallion around your neck in a
moment but the media are already
saluting biden's speech ray-ray
it was a fairly solid performance this
is a was a reminder of why people
elected joe biden right joe biden was
joe biden for most of this
most of this speech and i really think
you could see his gravitas every single
person stood with joe biden tonight i
thought that was joe biden at his best
uncle joe is back every single person is
standing with joe biden i don't know
what speech they saw but this did not
look like gravitas to me
putin may circle keeve with tanks
but he'll never gain the hearts and
souls of the iranian people preventing
russia's central bank from defending the
russell rubin ruble the pound of
ukrainian people the proud proud people
pound for pound it's time
to see
the
the what used to be called the rust belt
become this the the home of a
significant resurgence of manufacturing
increasing the productive capacity of
our economy our economy
i call it
building a better america
there's simply nothing beyond our mass
our capacity
thank you
go get him
go get him okay
lauren no is this a football game
i don't know but bear in mind the
president reportedly spent hours
rehearsing this speech at times he
looked lost he was squinting it was more
like the stare of the union he kept
looking off trying to figure things out
but you know look all of the kidding
aside leadership laura is about
unpredictability to keep your
adversaries on their toes and clarity of
communication joe biden had neither
tonight and as you watch the syntax slip
it communicated weakness unsteadiness
and frankly that's why we're seeing our
enemies emboldened and the media's
constant reported about ukraine
it all that does is distract from what i
thought was going to be domestic affairs
tonight instead it was the state of
ukraine that was the state of the
european union go ahead kind of yeah
it doesn't that doesn't hit home i mean
people
care deeply about it but people are
focused on home front costs
kids crime border right ukraine's part
of it but leading with ukraine
i i thought that was a miscalculation on
their part
this address
this address was notable laura for the
reappearance of that state of the union
performance artist nancy pelosi now when
president biden trump spoke she did her
pout and tear routine well this time she
was a spasmodic backup dancer popping up
and clapping making bizarre faces
readjusting her orthodontic but this
moment took the cake i call this dance
move of the hungry fly
from burn pits
many of you have been there
i've been in and out of iraq and
afghanistan over 40 times
laura she looks like a fly approaching
the sugar bowl you know but you know why
she's so excited joe biden is her
vitrola he plays out all of her agenda
hits right in dollar minimum wage free
child care build back better uh taking
on the gun industry she's delighting
she's almost like a ventriloquist i love
this that's what this excitement is oh
yeah we got to start doing this this is
going to be our new sign off laura the
funniest thing about this is that biden
hits the words burn pits
and she bolts up like out of her seat
like she's sitting on itching powder i
mean burn piss yes it's amazing i don't
know if she said she's got a second
career
she could do a sign she could be a
signer in one of those boxes next to
somebody you know she could be raymond
but what did you make uh raymond as we
begin the lenten season about biden's
calls for unity tonight
well it felt like lent came a heck of a
lot earlier uh like we've been in it for
two years but as he called for unity i
kept thinking he's been demonizing
police separating people by race and i'm
wearing this endymion dukel which i got
as grand marshal of a parade here in new
orleans we only have a few minutes left
of mardi gras but for anybody who took
part in it we saw races come together
with joy and love uh the outpouring of
communal affection that's unity joe
biden could take a lesson so could the
entire country
watch how americans can and should get
along and i love that we did it right
this mardi gras no it was beautiful we
were there i had uh maria my daughter
was there we had a lot of the ingram
angle
uh spirit and folks oh there's sam on
this on this chair do you see her there
she was just waiting yep um no but
raymond did a great job but it was it's
to be together we we need to be together
and find those moments of joy together
as a people and get
get through the difficulty with some
common sense and some patriotism um and
raymond you did a fantastic job for it
and dimi endymion thank you for inviting
us all in we're going to have other
announcements about what we discovered
in new orleans yes
nation coming in
happy mardi gras
happy mardi gras it's over
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else